- So we wanna put
our guest to work.
Champ Bailey. Top-three,
top-five corner all time?
- Damn. I think he's
in the top-five discussion.
I mean, I'm not just gonna go
out crazy and say top three.
- Hall of Famer?
- Hall of Famer.
- Hall of Famer. Get him in, get him in.
- Hands down.
- Come on, guys.
You can exaggerate a little.
- Only DB I ever
practiced against
that actually scared me
in practice.
- There's a lotta good wide
receivers in the league right now.
I wanna know
how you'd cover them.
First one: Tyreek Hill.
So, you're Tyreek Hill.
Step to the line.
- Oh, you know me.
I'm Tyreek Hill, all right.
- You're Tyreek Hill? OK.
- Yeah. You still
gonna get up there?
- Really?
- Absolutely.
I mean, we're both fast.
I won't do this every play,
but I gotta get in your face.
I gotta let you know I'm here.
- Right.
- I mean, that's my bread
and butter, bump-and-run.
Now, I'm not stupid.
- Right.
- This boy runs a 4.2,
maybe a 4.1
so I'm aware of that
before I play him.
So my idea of playing him
from the line of scrimmage
is I gotta stay
in front of him.
You hear this old cliche:
"Get your hands on him."
Man, forget that. It's not about
gettin' your hands on him.
It's about stayin'
in front of him
makin' it hard
for him to get there.
That's the easy one.
That's the one they want.
- And you're not gonna try
to jam him?
- Of course I'm gonna try
to jam him.
- OK, I thought
you weren't sure.
- No, the hands are secondary.
- I think you're crazy, Champ.
- The hands are secondary.
So I gotta stay on top of him.
If he wants to run
a 15-yard comeback, curl,
you can have that.
I'mma come down.
I'mma pound you all day.
- All right. I'm going time out–
- Right.
- Because I believe you've seen the film.
- Yeah.
- I think a lot of corners have thought
that with Tyreek Hill this year.
- Yeah.
- And that first–
- We're talking about me though, right?
- I know I'm talking about you.
- Set him straight!
- I know this–
- Just want to be clear.
but if he did open up on you and
it looked even faster than it was on film.
Are you coming out earlier? I'm just saying,
like, I haven't seen anyone in the NFL–
So you're saying that if my film study
didn't show the real speed or I didn't feel it
and now I'm surprised by–
- Yes. And you got out there
and he was faster than you
thought he was gonna be?
- And that happened before.
DeSean Jackson. You know, fast–
One of the fastest guys I've seen.
- Right.
- Probably fastest I've ever covered.
- He– he blew past me on the
first play and I'm chasing.
I'm like, "Oh my god, this guy's faster than I thought."
- Yeah.
- I played off him a little more than I wanted to but–
- Okay.
- At the same time, I still got up in
his face when I had the chance.
You know, it's just being aware
of what the situations are.
There's a lot of layers to it, man.
- Yes.
I could go on and on about–
- Let's do another one: Antonio Brown.
- OK.
- There's part of me
that believes
that if you saw Antonio Brown,
it's lockup status.
It's "I gotta get my hands on him
big-time." Super-physical.
Am I right?
- You're right.
I'mma tell you
why you're right.
Because film study tells me—
this is what I know because
I've played against him
I've seen him
throughout the years.
He has a hard time
with big, long corners.
- Right.
- Richard Sherman gives him hell.
- Hell.
- So I'm aware of that.
- And no one factors this into
the best wide receiver—
- Jalen Ramsey is givin' him hell.
- Give him hell, you know?
It's hard for him.
And why is it hard for him?
Because they stay in front
of him, they make it hard.
He can't run around him
he can't just wiggle
and just go.
The tape will tell you
everything. Tape doesn't lie.
- I agree.
- What about goin' toe-to-toe
with a Julio for that long?
Like, is that
physically demanding?
Like, are you exhausted more
after that game
than after a game
against Antonio Brown?
- You know, a guy like that,
he's bigger
so he's not gonna have
the same release
but he's stronger, so your feet
really play a role there
because if you're just standing
there with your arms out like this—
- Oh, you're getting tossed.
- He's just, you know, a la Brandon Marshall.
- Or he's gonna give
you the jerk-through.
- I mean, yeah.
These guys grab you.
They want you to grab 'em.
But I'll try to get
my hands on 'em
but it's really more
about my positioning.
You know, I just wanna make sure
that I have a strong foundation
because they'll throw you by,
they'll grab your helmet.
I mean, it doesn't matter.
Fitzgerald, he's the king of that.
He'll grab you, pull you.
- Right.
- And another thing you have to
worry about is blocking.
Those dudes block
their asses off.
- Of all the guys right now,
whether it's Odell, Julio
Keenan Allen, Antonio Brown,
DeAndre Hopkins, Tyreek Hill
which one are you goin'
"60 minutes—
I could get anything,
I could get everything
that's gonna cause me
to earn my paycheck the most?"
- Well, I think, uh, Odell
is probably the scariest
because his run after the catch
is superb.
I mean, his first step
There's really not a lot
of weaknesses in his game.
- Yeah.
- He can catch everything.
You know, his route
running is excellent.
- We've been saying this
for years.
- Oh, yeah?
- But people haven't believed us.
- Yeah, well, people
wanna hate on Odell.
- I get it. I mean,
he's a little flamboyant.
You know, he likes
the limelight, like to dance.
You know, so what?
- But he's still awesome.
- What does he do between the lines?
- Right, right.
- That's all that matters, right?
So, you know, that's why
people love to hate on T.O.
but T.O.'s one of the best ever.
- Yeah.
- And, you know, just, you know,
just watching his game
there's really not a lot
of weaknesses, plain and simple.
- Yeah.
- I love the fact that we got to
see how you play the guys.
The other aspect of defending
a wide receiver
the quarterback eyes.
- Mmhmm.
- We've had a few
secondary guys here—
Landon Collins,
Jamal Adams—
that kind of shared that staring
contest with the quarterback
and you're tryin'
to figure it out.
Is there one that pops
to your head right away
of, whether it's a Peyton
or a Brady or somebody
that game where
they either got you
or you got them really good?
- You know, uh,
Philip Rivers, probably.
One of those guys—he always
let you know when he got you.
You know, I hated him
for about two years.
- [Laughing]
- Great guy. Love him to death.
But he was just hard
to deal with
you know, because he would—
You could tell
he studied your weaknesses
because, you know,
he would find those moments
when you just weren't
paying attention.
And he knew he couldn't
attack me the whole game
but he had his moments where
he would just throw it in there
squeeze it in there,
and the guy was accurate.
The ball looks like
it's floating, but it's not.
- I feel like he would say
something, too.
- He would, yeah.
"Yeah, I got you right there."
Or, you know,
he'd come back and—
"You jumped that one.
Don't do that again."
Or something crazy like that.
It's, like, half the time
I don't know what he's saying
but I know he's just
talking trash and just—
You know, he's a competitive dude.
- Yeah.
- And I appreciate it more now
than I did then.
- You played with
Deion Sanders in D.C.
What was that year like
with him?
Like, what'd you learn from him,
just bein' around him?
- You know, it's not just him.
It was Darrell Green, too.
- Oh, man.
- So, I had Darrell Green
my rookie year—
- Holy cow.
- That's unbelievable.
- And then Deion comes in
and I got, OK,
two Hall of Famers.
They're already Hall of Famers
at that point.
- Right, right.
- So I'm thinking,
"OK, you  know
I got two guys
I can learn from."
First of all,
before he even got there
I'm worried if I'm gonna start.
But everybody made it clear
"Yeah, you're gonna start.
Of course you're gonna start."
- Of course you're gonna start.
- But I'm thinking, like
"These are two dudes
I look up to.
How do I start over them,
both of them?"
- Wow.
- In their prime, I'd have loved
to have seen them race—
all three of you, really.
That would've been a tight one.
- Ooh! I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Darrell was a track guy.
I was a track guy,
but I was a jumper
and Deion was a sprinter
as well, so that's hard.
I gotta say,
I gotta say Darrell
because he at least won
the Fastest Man contest.
- He won the Fastest Man
a few times.
- So I'll give him that.
- Yeah.
You'll give him that.
- So then what about you and Deion?
- You know,
maybe we're neck and neck.
You know,
I can't give him anything.
- I was gonna say, don't give it to him.
- Not on tape, not on tape.
- Don't give it to him.
- I was gonna say, don't give it to him.
- Not on tape, not on tape.
- Don't give it to him.
- Hall-of-Fame-worthy stories,
Simms has shared a lot from his career.
Beautiful 7, 8 years of NFL glory.
The poker games in Denver.
- [Laughing]
- We had fun.
- First of all, none of us liked to see
Champ walk in the room
when we were playing poker.
Like, we all loved Champ, but
Champ's pockets were
deeper than the rest of us, so–
You know, Champ–
- But I was the cheapest guy walkin' in there.
- He might have been the cheapest,
but he wasn't afraid to throw
a little money around every now and then.
- Every now and then.
- So he goes, "damn, I wanna buy him
out of this pot. I know he doesn't have crap."
- So he was a good bully.
- Yeah, he had big stacks of cash.
- That team with Denver, so who
would be in these poker rooms?
- Oh, man.
- Champ, Brandon Marshall,
LaMont Jordan—
- Scheffler.
- Tony Scheffler?
- Man, Tony Scheffler screwed me
out of $800 and left town
the last time we played.
- Really?
- Yeah. You hear that? I'm bringing
that up, Tony Scheffler.
- Should we go find him?
- I won $800 one night.
He—"Oh, well, I don't have
the money on me right now.
I'll bring by the check
in the next day or two."
- Real Lefkoe move.
And then he signed
with the Lions.
He signed with the Lions,
like, three days later.
I never saw him again.
One last for him, because I know
we're keeping you forever
The corners right now
in the NFL—
Not that you need to put a Mount Rushmore.
But, like, who are the two or three
that jump out to you right now
Where you just go, "Damn.
That's a special— special group."
- Ah. Man.
- I know there's some good ones right now.
- I could go on and on
I think one steady guy that's been
impressive is Patrick Peterson
- Yeah.
- You know, I mean, to make the Pro Bowl
every year you've been in the league
Unbelievable
Another guy, we just talked about.
Byron Jones
- Yeah
- I mean, he's starting to stick
out a little more cuz—
I really focus on guys who have that
tough task of matching up every week
- Right
- That is a nightmare, you know?
- Man.
- And he does it and he's done well
- Michael Thomas did nothing
- Nothing
- Right
- It's because that dude is a technician
- Yes
- He is a technician
What do you got
going on right now?
- Oh, well, you know, I invested
in this company, BW Health
and basically they make
these socks, Lasso Socks
and what they do,
they mimic ankle taping
and one thing every athlete
hates is taping their ankles.
- Yes.
- You know—
- It's the worst, isn't it?
- It's the worst.
- These things feel so good.
I wear 'em every day.
Got 'em on now.
And for an old guy
that doesn't run around anymore
I can only imagine
if I was young and playing
what these would do for me.
You wanna know more
about it, LassoGear.com
tell you everything
about the sock.
Backed by technology.
Great socks.